i have a daughter who is 17 years old
and i see how influenced she is by
seeing other and meeting
and seeing other really impressive
women how it it it shows her that she
can
accomplish anything and whenever i get a
chance i try to introduce her
to anybody i can michelle obama a you
anyone who
who my daughter can see so that she
knows she can accomplish pretty much
anything in this life
and impact this show that you're doing
is really a great idea
you're you're highlighting women who are
superheroes because they live in the
real world and they're making themselves
excellent examples uh for young women
out there how did this idea come about
totally they walk their walk um so for
for a long time i mean after the success
of wonder woman and fame
and all of that i just felt like super
privileged and grateful that i have such
a big access to
people's life through social media and
and all of that and i wanted to do
something meaningful with that and
something good
um so iran my husband and i were looking
for the right project
for quite some time and when we
finally met ryan polata who is a young
director who did a piece about this
amazing brazilian ballet dancer from the
favelas in rio
we completely fell in love with her
story we fell in love with her with her
determination with her leadership
and with the fact that you know
even though she comes from such a
complicated background
um she has the force
and the ability and the want to change
and to
influence her her her
community and then we just decided okay
so we have an idea let's find
different type of stories that are
driven by
different women that will show their
impact in their communities and it was
such a and then it all you know and then
it all became real
um but to me they're all super inspiring
because
you know it's women that went through
tough life right with violence or
discrimination or poverty or
trauma or oppression or whatever it
might be
instead of letting it bringing them down
they turned it into a strength they
let it fuel them into doing
something and and and try to better
their
world and it's so selflessness and it's
so beautiful
and you know whenever i speak to these
women i'm like you're the true hero it's
not about me
i know people are we're gonna talk about
it and all it's you
you're the heroes you walk the walk i
read lines and i'm being hanged on wires
and all of that
yeah but you are true true life
heroes and i'm very grateful that they
let us share their stories
i think it's also to me what's important
is that
there are a lot of images a lot of
people
that are putting images out on instagram
that get a following
because of how they look and
yeah and i and i think that it's really
great to highlight
stories of people that have had an
experience
like an incredible experience or have
developed an amazing skill
i think those are great role models for
not just
young women but young men too but
especially women need to see that now so
that it's not
all who's your favorite instagram
influencer
you know totally totally that there is
something meaningful there it's like
you know it's funny because now i do
this thing where i ask my
my daughter
but alma i would ask her what do you
want to be when you grow up right
or i'll ask the friends and you'll be
surprised by the amount of kids that
gonna say
famous yeah and then i'll go along with
it and say okay famous for what
and then it's like uh uh you know then
it gets confusing
right but i think i think that you know
i being a mother and
you know be coming from the background
that i i came from and
all of that being an immigrant in
america and all that
i want to be able to bring
meaningful stories to life i'm a big
believer in storytelling and i think
that
good stories has the power to change
um and i hope that people are going to
be
able to connect to it once they watch i
think they will
we have a clip here and this is i
believe
uh the ballet school is that right yeah
from brazil
from brazil let's take a look at this
clip from impact
with gal gadot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm fascinated by one thing which is
that you are working with your husband
on this project now my wife and i we've
been married
19 years we have an excellent
relationship
we never work together we do separate
things
and so i'm very curious about this does
it if
if you're working with your spouse does
that ever get difficult
yes it gets difficult from time to time
yeah but i think we kind of figured it
out once we decided that it's okay to
to disagree right okay um
and from that moment on it's kind of
been
[Music]
super smooth yep uh but
you know for us it's just a different
there's all
different type of relationships yawn and
i are very
close and we're very um
you know we see eye to eye on most
things
and to be able to work with the person
that you trust the most and you love the
most and you
you know respect so much is the best
because he and i care for the same
things
um and it's kind of great you know
people have been telling me
it's been so hard with my partner
throughout yeah
i'm like uh you know we've been
living this way for quite some time
we're like always together
right um but it's been it's been
what was that what's fufu-fu what's that
food
it's like uh it's like you do it against
evil eye
is it is it what it's like from from
from
like i think israeli well police jewish
or something
fufu knock on wood
when you knock on wood yeah you say it's
food food
food food food spit it's like oh i spit
i have to spit
okay well that's i'm i'll teach you
anything you like